[Music]
what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg and john here today
we got to talk about some stuff right
now it's very important that we do i
know we're late to it i was in the
middle of working on a couple of things
when the marvel animation panel was
going on so i missed a lot of this
information i was a few hours late to
finding out the specifically spider-man
freshman year because there's a lot of
qualities about spider-man freshman year
that i am so jazzed about very excited i
love a good spider-man animated series
grew up on the 90s one love spectacular
spider-man so seeing this and seeing
some of the first images i'm like oh
yeah this is gonna be fun then there's
this other part of me that's just so
equally puzzled by what they're doing
that i found myself going down a
wormhole of like wait i'm lost let me
make sure that i remembered my
information correctly and then i looked
at the disney plus press release and it
said spider-man freshman year is bait
it's basically confirming that it's the
prequel to captain america civil war at
least like not prequel but take place
before then showing his journey into
becoming spider-man tom holland's
version right and that's when this
raised a lot of questions in spider-man
freshman year when looking at these
images there was a couple of things that
i was excited to see explored because
you know by the time you meet him in
civil war he'd only been spider-man i i
don't remember how long it had been i my
memory saying it was only like six
months but it might have been longer
than that i could be way wrong you feel
fear to correct me but he hadn't been
spider-man for that long and so seeing
like the early prototype images again
and watching the journey oh it's nice to
actually fill in this gap and really get
the origin of it all and maybe there'll
be an uncle ben maybe maybe
but the way they're writing this show
i'm like this seems like you could throw
an uncle ben in there even though
spider-man no way home kind of made it
feel like there was never an uncle ben
to begin with there will be a really
emotional scene where uncle ben tells
aunt may that with great power comes
great responsibility that she could pass
it on and then they've revealed that
daredevil is gonna be in the show and i
love the look of daredevil's new outfit
it is super super sick and knowing
charlie cox is returning to voice
daredevil that was great it did raise an
eyebrow for a second but i went then i
went wait never mind this works because
you know when you see matt murdock
representing peter parker and spider-man
no way home daredevil could have met
spider-man but that doesn't mean
daredevil learned who spider-man
actually is so it doesn't mess with the
mcu cannon but then some other [ __ ]
starts to really mess with mcu cannon if
not executed properly like already i
started that's why i had to re-look at
wait what was the press release on this
because this is so confusing and then i
was going online i'm like okay i'm not
alone other people are confused about
this too because this is really weird i
mean they reveal the look at
the villains that are gonna be featured
in this show which of course is exciting
and and i didn't even question it at
first because i saw doc ock and looking
at doc ock you know it's the classic
animated suit you know it looks so
classic then i saw scorpion i'm like oh
cool scorpion's gonna be in the show too
and then i went hold the phones
something's really off about this
situation to me here so did we just
forget all these people who met peter
parker before or was there so i mean dr
strange is supposed to be in this dude
did he like erase peter's memory of all
these people because yeah it just seems
like there's such blatant lack of
continuity with the thing they directly
said they wanted to show the backstory
of here yeah because if as you recall in
spider-man no way home you know they
laugh at the thought or sight of otto
octavius scorpion doesn't at least
the way it registers in the movie
spider-man homecoming it doesn't really
become scorpion until the end of that
film where it seemed like they were
setting us up to get a scorpion but we
ultimately didn't right but especially
with auto octavius you would think that
peter parker and no way home would have
some kind of reaction to i know an auto
octavia's here and now i'm eating a
different version you're not the real
one maybe there's a way to write it off
like okay maybe that just wasn't said or
some some [ __ ] but then then they
revealed this i don't know the order in
which they revealed stuff i'm telling
you the order and how i found stuff out
that norman osborne is gonna be in the
series along with harry osborne they
look cool i don't care that they're
black or some people probably are going
to throw a hissy fit yeah you're not mad
you're not panicking if you're not mad
you don't love marvel the way you're
supposed to look right these characters
you're supposed to love marvel because
you love diversity
i don't care like who cares that's great
good awesome you know it's sometimes i
just don't question things at first
because i just norman osborne is a part
of the peter parker journey yeah but
then again going back to no way home
norman osborne says when he lands here
on earth 616 he doesn't there's no
oscorp here he also freaking according
to these photos and images that we have
here peter parker looks like he's best
friends with harry osborn yeah which of
course is more canon to the actual story
of peter parker but does that line up
with the tom holland mcu version that
we've gotten peter has no reaction at
all to seeing an alternate universe
norman osborne i could even give the
show
some type of leeway if there's not an
oscorp established like if it's called
something else that way they don't have
to worry about that continuity error i
still feel like there's a gap here
that's kind of missing for me yeah i
mean you look at it from the outside and
it begs you to do like a lot of
contortions to imagine how this could
make sense and not disrupt everything
because you're like okay so did duck get
sent back and go no no i gotta go get
peter parker again but i'm gonna go to
the past at a different point there's
just so much uh convolution for
something they promised it at first
sounding very simple and then they threw
this in here which made me start
questioning a little bit more again i
don't know the order and how they unveil
things i'm saying and then they threw
this in here but i don't know the order
they have this look of spider-man suits
first thought oh sweet we're gonna get
alternate spider-man suits and then you
go back to the question of canon wait a
minute hold on a second
the classic looking spider-man suit in
freshman year like when did you have the
classic looking suit so is it gonna be
something that crosses over from like
it's gonna some of it's gonna take place
before civil war and then some of it's
gonna take place after civil war that
would make sense to me but what about
all these other suits like where the
hell did these come from this looks like
a person who would have encounters with
like the multiverse and other versions
of spider-man that's the only way i
could see it when did all these get
built or when did he try all these out
because when you watch those mcu movies
it seemed like it was whatever tony gave
me yeah yeah yeah yeah this is the the
mandated upgrade to your janky homemade
suit and it came from a very specific
place so so yeah it's like how would you
run through all this like this must be
the longest freshman year
like possible the more you hear about it
the more it feels like it ought to be a
stand-alone thing because then it would
make sense and then it would be like
okay maybe it'll touch the mcu but it's
not setting out to originate something
that is so heavily kind of tied to the
mcu specifically you know they are
bringing back charlie cox but tom
holland is not voicing peter parker in
this show was that a very intentional
choice because they're gonna have to
explain some of this [ __ ] maybe you know
i don't know like at this point because
of the multiverse my mind again goes
they could explain this any number of
ways and the main concern that i have
hearing all these things and there's
like it'll be doctor strange and there's
going to be characters from runaways and
there's going to be all these things and
it just feels so kind of complicated
yeah again and and it's all coming back
to that sticking point of this is going
to be the origin story of tom holland's
peter parker and the more i hear about
this just the more it doesn't feel like
it's got anything to do with that yeah
i'm excited for it i'm excited for it
i'm just totally i'm just totally
puzzled by a lot of the choices when i
think about canon if this was just some
stand-alone thing not a single question
but that one aspect is making me
question everything about
what they're doing when mcu is so much
about timeline and continuity what does
mcu mean now you know what are they
saying that yeah no it's still mcu but
it's a different it's a different peter
oh or are you talking about it
i thought this was the tom holland
it's all the well they're gonna have to
call it the mcm now they're gonna have
to go with the cinematic multiverse the
one continuity the sacred timeline is
breaking up and i feel like once you get
past phase four and beyond it's gonna be
harder and harder to explain that once
upon a timeline that was unified i don't
know leave your thoughts down below guys
subscribe click that bell see for more
comic con goodies
[Music]